We talked a lot about the cells as a whole,
but in this video
we will focus on plant cells,
the focus is on plant cells.
This is it
drawing of a plant cell.
The first thing that can make you impression is,
that instead
rounded shape,
like that of many other cells I've painted,
this has a form
cube or prism.
This is because we have a plant cell and
it may have such a structure.
The next question is -
what gives this form of plant cells.
What allows them to have
this form of cube or prism?
The answer is the cell wall.
This is the cell wall.
Let us orient ourselves correctly
in this drawing.
Of course, if that part had not been cut off,
we would only see the outer part of the cage.
We would only see the cell wall.
But we cut that piece down and we can see
different layers of the interior of the cell.
We have the cell wall outside.
Just below it we have
cell membrane
or plasma membrane.
This is the cell membrane.
The cell membrane is below the cell wall.
Under the cell membrane
is the cytoplasm.
And in the cytoplasm
there are many different things.
That's the big thing he's taking
a very large volume of the interior of the plant cell
is the vacuum for which we have spoken
in other videos.
Vacuola.
The combinations of
internal pressure, organelles such as vacuole
and the pressure
of all the fluids in the cage
exerts pressure on the outside, and the cell wall
keeps everything inside the cage.
This gives the structure of the plants.
Therefore, the plants can grow
and face it.
Plants can grow upright.
I paint a plant.
Actually I have a plant in my room,
what I am looking at right now,
it can grow upright.
So, we have a cell wall,
cell membrane,
as well as other organelles.
Here we have chloroplasts,
they are very important for photosynthesis. These are our good friends
mitochondria.
We have a nuclear shell
or more precisely, the yellow thing
is the internal nuclear membrane.
This shell is DNA.
We have an endoplasmic network.
-
The grainy endoplasmic grid
there are ribosomes on the membrane.
The smooth endoplasmic grid has no ribosomes.
The Goldie Apparatus. It was small
negotiation.
We will now concentrate on the cell wall.
Let's get back to her.
If we want to look at the cell wall closely,
we can look at it
this diagram.
Here, it may surprise you
less.
Before, when I thought about
the cell wall I imagined
something like a brick wall.
Something impenetrable.
But this painting gives us
different idea.
To make it clearer,
this is our cell membrane
-
therefore here we have
double lipid layer.
It is located on it
the cell wall.
As you can see, she is not fat
like a brick wall, like something
impenetrable.
You see that it consists of all these polysaccharides
fibers that pass through it.
We have things like pulp,
which, as we have seen, is a polymer of glucose,
arranged in a specific way.
Hemi-cellulose, which has different species
monomers.
We have pectin, which is another
polysaccharide.
You probably ate
all these things, if not today, at least
last week. When we talk about a diet rich in
fiber, talk about things
such as cellulose and pectin.
Things your digestive system can not bend.
When you eat a plant, you get fiber,
because you eat the cell walls of the plant.
They do good things like
delayed glucose absorption
in the gut.
Water is absorbed, so we can say that
things go through the digestive system a little faster.
But the basic thing is that this is not the case here
wall.
She says -
It's actually a wall.
Officially, a cell wall,
but it is not a thick impermeable wall,
properties that you can associate
with the walls of the room you are in.
You see there are bumps through which you can
pass small molecules.
More like a network or
on fabric.
In fact, the cell membrane
has access to the liquid
and to the molecules that are present
between cells.
To make it clear
we see:
this layer here is the cell membrane,
this is the double lipid layer.
This is it
the cell wall.
I need another color.
This is the cell wall.
And just above the cell wall
is the space between the cells,
which is called the middle lamella.
The space between the cells
we call the middle lamella.
It's here too
middle lamella.
All this is interesting, but you can ask yourself,
"How solid is the cage?"
"I understand that the wall is like a net, but the cells,
plants can stand upright. "
"Does the cell wall give them
all the hardness? "
The answer is - somewhat.
The cell is like this network,
it keeps the shape of the cells.
But if you stop watering a plant,
you will see that it
slamming.
This happens as part of his ability
Standing upright comes from internal pressure
in the cells.
Another part of the form of the plant comes from itself
cell wall.
Now you might say,
"Well, I've seen plants,
which are much harder than the plant,
which you drew. "
"What about things like trees?"
"The wood?"
"The wood looks very hard."
"It's so hard that
we can build real wood walls. "
The answer is that with these
more mature plants once the cell stops
to grow and have ours
cell wall may accumulate further
layers of cellulose and other molecules,
forming a so-called secondary cell wall.
We can see this as primary
cell wall.
And over it can be built thicker
a secondary cell wall that gives the plant
much more hardness.
It gives it
the structure of the wood
even if we take away all the water,
even if we dehydrate it,
the wood will still have
hardness due to the layers of cellulose
and other molecules that are
so thick that
they allow her to keep her temper.
I'm going to the last thing I'm talking about.
We have already seen that
cell membrane has access to
the molecules that swim
between the cells, but there is also
direct tunnels between adjacent plant cells.
I've drawn these direct tunnels here,
on the outside of the cell walls,
these yellow circles are
plasmodesms.
These are plasmodeisms.
To better understand what
represent, imagine that this is a cage.
Here I write cell 1.
Let's say this is cell 2.
Box 2 is here.
The cells are cut across.
You can see that plasmodes are
these tunnels that are formed
-
between the two cells.
As a result, cytosol or
small molecules can be exchanged directly
between these two cells.
We will explain the structure of these tunnels in some detail,
we have
this tube from the endoplasmic mesh,
which goes through Plasmodeism.
But I want to be very clear.
Very often when you study biology
everything is explained in the textbook
and it looks clear and clear.
But people are still studying the question of why
there are plasmodeisms.
What do you need?
What is transported through them?
and how,
under what conditions?
If you get deeper
very little in some of these questions,
which I have listed,
you will get to the zone of active
Research.
I hope that in this video
learn a little more
for the trees around you,
for plants, domestic plants
and even for the salad you can
was eaten at noon.